Hi, my name is Gordon Ramsay.
Welcome to Chef Support.
Today, we'll be doing Twitter.
Right.
First question.
Hannah.
Question to those of you who are good in a kitchen,...
...how do I mince garlic without a press?
I'm going to show you.
Take the clove of garlic.
This part of the knife, on there.
And, literally, hand on there.
And that is super minced.
Touch of salt in there...
...and just chop it.
And within seconds, you got this paste...
...because look, the salt keeps it together...
...and it stops it from oozing out unto the board.
In ten seconds, you got this beautiful minced garlic.
The back of the knife.
Good question.
Now, can cheese go bad?
I'm eating this cheese and it tastes funny but I'm a bit hungry.
Come on, Adam.
Seriously?
The worst thing to do with cheese is take it out of the fridge,...
...let it get up to room temperature,...
...leave it out for 24 hours and then refrigerate it.
That's the worst thing you can do.
Once you've taken it out and it's gotten really runny,...
...you have to eat it or discard it.